hey everybody hopefully you can see this
cuz I am NOT a hundred percent sure
about this signal I got with this phone
but we are here out having a grand old
time I'm here with my buddy mark who you
might remember from our fighting a bank
fishing video from a couple months ago
and we're camping on this river here and
just doing a catch cook fishing camping
video it's just having a great time hey
everybody yeah how you do it
but yeah we we got here about early
afternoon and we've got a fire going
over there we've got Tommy eating a hot
dog in his pajamas let's see here get to
get the screen a little less fuzzy hey
thanks Josh appreciate the support there
thank you very much but yeah we we've
been having a great time we doing a
catch and cook video oh and we cooked up
some fish and chips here on the bank and
I just got done eating that and the boys
didn't want anything to do with it so
they're having hot dogs yeah you guys
having fun yeah there you go there's
Nate did you know Nate don't dip don't
eat that no buddy if you dip it in the
river you're gonna get diarrhea okay
don't don't eat food you dipped in the
river see little tip for you guys there
don't eat food you dipped in a river
okay here ya go wash it off with some
bottled water and you can probably still
eat it
maybe ya know take that go take that
over to go go look he's gonna hit he'll
wash it off with clean water
don't use the don't don't use the water
from the river and tomorrow's episode
we'll talk about not getting drinks with
ice while in Mexico too so you know a
whole bunch of tips there travel tips
yeah don't don't do the lake water any
rain hey yeah so we've been having a
good time we've been doing some fishing
the fishing hasn't been great
but this is kind of one of those
situations where we picked the spot
based on the fact that we've got four
small children with us as opposed to
ideal fishing but this place is just
amazing I mean look at this we got a
beach the water is not too too deep
there so the kids have been swimming in
the river all day long and got a few
fish we've got some some eels and
catfish and bass and everything any rate
only got one rod out right now and I'm
fishing with some catfish roe believe it
or not so I'm gonna give that a try and
see what happens any rate so yeah anyway
so this is kind of what we're doing one
of the reasons why I wanted to do this
live stream too is you know YouTube
still disabled our comments and we
cannot get that undone so it's nice to
be able to interact with you guys and
just be able to hear some feedback I'd
like to know how you guys eyes what you
guys think of the videos you know we've
got been doing a lot of cooking videos
I'm gonna try to mix it up a little bit
and do some camping videos obviously but
I've got at least one more cooking video
I'm gonna post it's a like barbecuing
and that sort of thing so Oh any rate
aid just one rod I'm amazed yeah yeah
that's not my standard operating
procedure but uh anyway let's see
somebody was asking some questions he
whisker stick fishing if you guys happen
to travel
through cincinnati hemisphere time love
to host you for some big fishing well
thank you hey by the way I've got some
whisker stick lights I'm gonna be using
tonight so we're gonna do some night
fishing so if you guys ever need those
the lights on your rods check out those
whisker sticks rod withdrawals
oh you have more survival camping
actually guys I've got a really awesome
I've got an underground stealth survival
shelter that I've been working on for a
long time that video is coming up hey
thank you I am no one thank you for the
five bucks I appreciate that that does
it oh oh oh man who is it a David Hogue
broke his arm can't go fishing I'm sorry
to hear that buddy
hang in there mend why did the small
boat because it's a small River you guys
there was put it this way there I
someone was asking why I have a small
boat today it's because there was no
boat launch
we did some we did some extreme boat
launching to get to this spot there's a
reason why it's Memorial Day weekend and
there's nobody here
okay it's not because it was easy to get
here let me tell you that love the
survival videos oh thank you oh we're
gonna we're gonna try to do some more
I'm survival videos I was like the
survival camping videos always seemed
like a better thing to do in the
wintertime you know when it's 70 degrees
and and sunny is surviving in the woods
isn't very impressive hey doesn't really
require a lot of tips yeah any rate how
does the sand taste gritty
does yes let's yeah
oh yeah but people all people bunch
people asking questions well listen I'm
not gonna make this too long but if you
guys have any questions for me go ahead
and let me let me know but to kind of
give you guys an update of what's going
on we we've got some fun trips planned
I'm going to we're gonna be spending
three weeks in England and here this
summer and I'm really looking forward it
love love traveling to England great
great time so we're gonna really go all
over the place we're gonna go to Devon
which is in the southwest of England for
a week we rented a house with a private
lake and we're gonna be like fishing
like crazy and then we're going to the
Peak District which is kinda in the
middle the Midlands kind of area and
then we're gonna go up to Scotland for a
week so we're gonna we're gonna get over
and try some some parts of the UK that
we haven't seen before
Blake Hayes asked if I bass fish yes I
do one week from tomorrow I am posting a
bass fishing video on the catfish and
carp YouTube channel so if you guys want
that that's coming a week from tomorrow
also a lot of guys we're gonna this
summer I'm going to try to do two videos
a week here on the outdoor boys YouTube
channel as well as the catfish and carp
YouTube channel it's not gonna be a
hundred percent I'm not holding myself
to any unrealistic schedules but I have
a lot of small videos or our videos that
re-edited like France one thing I've
been actually now that we have comments
I wanted to ask you guys about is our
world tour videos which were huge okay
yeah they just it was like a twelve part
series we spent a month traveling around
and fishing and in last year Irie added
it down to one video that's an hour and
a half so I it'll dit down by a by two
thirds so it's it's only thirty percent
the length of the original one but it's
still an hour and a half it's a month of
videoing as we traveled the world I'm
gonna repost that here that re-edit soon
and I've got a lot of others I got some
short videos some some kind of just ones
that we're kind of goofy I did an axe
restoration video that kind of you know
went squirrelly on me and so I haven't
posted it so oh I'm gonna I'm gonna do
I'm gonna post those try to post those
on Wednesdays here this summer and it
see how it goes but yeah we'll see so
hopefully you guys are gonna get double
the videos this summer on both channels
it's Monza's asked me to shout at him I
don't know I'm not angry at you
why do you want to do a shout out hey
catfish bill hey thanks for the things
for the donation appreciate that we'd
love to see some live bait fishing for
bass
oh-hoo-hoo Adrian Garza thank you very
much for the generous donation really
appreciate let me see you had a question
on there so Lou's for uh saludos from
South Texas hey thank you thank you
shout out to South Texas anything I do
want to go to Texas my good friend Jeff
is moved down there and we've been
wanting to visit him forever any rate so
people was asking about live bait
fishing for bass I've got a video in
cats and carp channel a week from
tomorrow on just that subject so that's
cool man that little toasty is is
instructing me on what a shout out needs
aids I think yeah my my my feigned
ignorance wasn't uh wasn't appreciated
yeah let's see let's see what's the best
bluegill bait a probably earthworms blue
gills Leila are always loved earthworms
but there's you know if you don't have
or there's a lot of other things and
sometimes in certain situations other
baits work well
we're trying to try to do more camping
videos I see so hey I'm no.1 thank you
thank you come to the Nebraska Missouri
River I would love to I mean there are
so many places we want to we want to
travel interestingly enough my wife is
kind of kind of on this idea that we buy
like an outdoor boys cats and carp
trailer like a little fifth wheel and
that we can then go in and tour the
country a little bit more easily as a
entire family go do videos that she's
she's actually kind of digging on that
idea a little bit so who knows maybe
maybe we'll get a get a little trailer
and then we'll go do a big tour and go
hit all these wonderful States and I've
always wanted to fish you know okay so
out of people telling me to come to
Michigan go fish it admission in it
looks like someone else is going to
Scotland as well we're gonna have a good
time man gonna be representing how are
the mosquitoes mosquitoes are not a
problem is then hasn't been buggy at all
it's been been awesome what states do I
want to go to you Oh life is so many
there's so many go to the Soviet Union
somebody says yeah I can't my time
machine's broken
but I I did study a little bit of
Russian back in the days but Oh Jim no
no go ngati porou ski Oh Jim so maybe
one day I'll get to go out and and go
hook up with some crazy Russians out in
Siberia and we'll go catch wels catfish
and burbot and through the ice with guns
or something I don't know
hey well maybe one day let's see
Lake Erie great place for fly heads bet
it is go to Puerto Rico I have been to
Puerto Rico oh it was it was lovely it
was lovely but yeah maybe one of these
days we'll have to go back let's see
Cumberland River below Barclay actually
I was just texting Steve Douglas about
doing another fishing trip to the
Barclay dam for Asian carp I really
think it would be awesome to go do a big
like multi-day a like fishing
get-together or I invite all of our
subscribers and stuff and we go out and
try everything we can to try to catch
Asian carp on baits and I'm just
convinced I want you know Russians do it
Japanese do it Chinese do it a lot of
people catch Asian carp with bait and
hook and there's you know but I've just
never been able to see somebody do it I
want to learn how to do it so I keep
telling Steve we need to go out and give
it another try and we should do like a
big like a fishing event and then just
have a big barbecue or we go cook up all
the Asian carp because Asian carp are
delicious they did what's what's the
name of where you at
let's see dance fishing thank you for
the donation I appreciate
just don't let Steve use the knife oh
yeah that was so gross that was so gross
man opened himself up have you fished
for sturgeon yes yes my biggest sturgeon
was eight and a half feet long I've
caught two sturgeon over eight feet
let's see what's the best catfish bait
fresh-cut bait fish like gizzard shad or
skipjack or you know perch or whatever
they do you like salmon yes I grew up in
Alaska I love salmon they go pike
fishing I would love to do a pike
fishing video you know in Alaska when I
grew up pike fishing were trash fish and
you know the old joke people tell about
car pal the only way to cook a carp is
to cook it on a board and you throw the
carp away and eat the board by the law
that was the same joke everyone Alaska
told about pike
they were destructive of the
they were horrible I was always told if
he catch a pike you throw it in the
bushes and kill it and my sister married
avid fisherman from Cleveland who loved
a pike fish and we teased him
relentlessly about being a trash
fisherman and everything and then one
day he finally convinced us to go pike
fishing and we went out to some lake in
Alaska and I caught 83 Pike in one day
and it was amazing and we ate some and
they were fine and they're delicious and
and hey thank you for the Nathan thank
you for the donation but anyway it kind
of opened my eyes you know because you
know I've heard all my life that Pike
was this horrible you know disgusting
terrible fish and they're not you know
they're they're just a fish like any
other fish you know and so when I came
down to the States and I started hearing
people saying the same thing about carp
I didn't believe it because you know
I've been through that before it or you
know and sure enough yeah carp there
just another fish every used car for cut
bait I have I've never had a ton of
success though I'm a few times I've
fished for it it's been kind of meh you
know and bluegill and gizzard shad are
so easy to get around here and they're
works so much better so you know
whatever but a small live carp it's hard
to beat for flat heads you know
oh but anyway let's see how oh let's see
shout out to shout out to BGH bottom
feeders for saying no shoutouts hey Matt
let's see let's see goldfish for Bay
what is the best bass bait now so many
different chef rod and reel reviews you
know I did a ton of them a couple years
ago
I just went bonkers and I I spent I
think I spent four or five thousand
dollars buying rods and
so I could review him because you know
most of these reviews on YouTube that
people aren't paying for this crap and
reviewing it they're they're getting
sent it you know I get probably twelve
fifteen solicitations a day from people
asking me to review their products for
money or whatever and any rate so I
decide no I know I'm just gonna I'm
gonna straight-up buy this stuff give it
an honest review and I don't I'm not
beholden to anybody and I did it it was
it was good stuff but it was a lot of
work for not a lot of results you know
those videos weren't that popular and so
I don't know if I'll do a ton of them
again maybe here and there as I buy
something just for my own personal use
uh you know if I find any products I
like I always tell you guys about it but
just doing straight up rod review real
review videos is kind of not very good
yeah let's see ever used rum for cut
bait no I have it
member of the American carp Society I
used to be members of all these
different like fishing societies and
stuff and then I just basically got to
the point where it was like these are
just lots of people arguing online about
stuff you know I just kind of don't kind
of disengaged over the years I've kind
of got my feel of people having online
discussions about fishing to do how many
years have I been fishing many oh let's
see you brain carp to new Lana okay yeah
thank you
let's see I'm scrolling through what do
you like catching I like catching a
little bit of everything
well hold on Nathan what you do it you
swim in you know you bet you get out
you're not gonna dry out too much I love
swimming
yeah it's getting sunset you're not
gonna dry out if you keep going
do you having fun Nathan oh yeah let's
see somebody asked when I was going to
Alaska next we have no plan to go to
Alaska
um but whenever we do it'll probably be
in the wintertime our next trip I'd
really hey we'll go next February I
don't know go see the Iditarod I think
that would be way cool
go do some ice fishing and skiing and
snow machining dog sledding and stuff
like that do a minnow trapping video
well say hey Nate come on up upstream
buddy yeah yeah you want to go walk go
up see let's see any rate like but hey
there's just a quick little little life
just a quick little live stream it just
kind of giving you guys an update you
got a lot of things coming up a lot of
things working on a lot of videos and a
rate but anyway I hope you guys enjoy
this video and just stay tuned we'll be
we post every Saturday morning so we got
some great videos coming up tomorrow
morning anyway thanks for everyone for
tuning in and have a great day